hello everyone and welcome back to the
Magnusson Invitational we are starting
Game three of the magic England versus
onigiri Game one between the two of them
ended in a draw for some reason I said
the previous video was Game one even
though the previous video was game to
game two went Dingley run and this is
now Game three with gear is still being
without a win in the entire tournament
so ding now leading the match he you
know I needs only two draws to win the
match and let's see let's see how it
goes
so ding with the white pieces starts
with the d4 sorry about that and we have
Knight to f6 by giri we have C 4 and the
g6 Giri also goes for the Kings Indian
defense and Knight to f3 we've got the
g7 and now III we have castles and
Bishop to e2 c5 challenging the center
and the d5 of course advancing the pawn
we have d6 and now Knight to c3 and here
is exchanging this d5 pawn so basically
we we switch over to a benoni structure
we have ninth to be to this night is
coming to c4 if we're going to have a
trade in the center so the knight will
be useful on c4 attacking the d6 pawn
but Knight to a6 giri giri just Waits
now with the tension in the center we
have castles now sorry castles by not
loki eight castles by white and now rook
to e8 and E for now just strengthening
the center and now there is one game in
the database for knife the c7 was played
but here we have b6 preparing to open up
the light square bishop and it is as of
move tendered we have a completely new
game so let's see what gear we prepared
in a well as he is down in the match he
should definitely win together to get
back into the match so here ding the
captures on e6 we have D captures Bishop
captures and now as the knight will no
longer have the C 4 square for you know
as an outpost he goes a nice the B
theory which is not not a great square
for the knight it's a very unclear where
this night is going to anytime soon but
okay Queenie 7 Giri connects the rooks
rooks and the bush of the f4 now Dean
says okay you have a backwards
sexpun I'm now going to pile up on it so
rook a to be a to give a defense and the
Queen to d2 now being also connects
rooks precursor bring the rook into the
game and now tonight the b4 by giri and
okay rook a2 b1 brings a third attacker
to the pawn here but now Queen to b7
giri just moves out of the way and says
okay if we if you capture we just trade
I'm gonna capture on e4 and the Queen
also supports my knight so f 3 ding
strengthens the pawn says okay I'm gonna
capture now but Giri says no you don't
and goes Queen to a6 now with a double
attack on the c4 pawn so dink once again
a three kicks away the knight Knight to
c6 and nights the be five blocks the
Queen's attacked a tap on says okay I'm
gonna grab on d6 and the next move but
Giri says no you're not and goes Queen
to a4 now again with a double attack on
the c4 pawn but also attacking the
knight on b3 so here Queen c2 defending
against the both ideas saying okay I'm
probably gonna capture on the next move
but Giri says nope
and not gonna happen Knights the a5 and
now puts a double attack on the night
here and also a triple attack on the c4
pawn so here being decided that it's
time to trade Queens so night the night
three to d4 or now opening up an attack
against the givers queen and here Geary
trades Queen captures Knight captures
and now Bishop captures in c4 finally
grabbing that pawn with Bishop captures
and c4 Knight captures attacking the b2
born while also defending his d6 pawn so
b3 the getting rid of one of the
defenders of the d6 pawn and now a6 not
moving the knife but rather attacking
one of the attackers of the d6 pawn so
here
dingus said okay be captures and c4 a
character son b5 and see capture son b5
and now as the d6 pawn is still under
attack Geary just advances that with d5
and now all of a sudden we have this
position where the material is equal but
got rid of his weakness on b6
okay here you could just play characters
captures it doesn't seem to be anything
wrong with that but ding decides to go
for the active Knights the e3 I kind of
provoking the four so you could go night
here and put pressure on the b61 also
brush of the c7 can also put additional
pressure on the b6 pawn
however the giri just grabs the pawn d
captures on e4 and as it's protected by
the night and the rook as well it's a
free pawn
so Dean continues Bishop to c7 goes
after the rook and the pawn here but now
rook to d3 gets the rook away with tempo
as the knight is under attack now and
the ding doesn't want to capture here
and give Geary the the past the d3 pawn
so rook F e1 defending and now rook
captures on e3
he reaches grabs another pawn and now
again if you go for Bishop captures pawn
then he captures on f3 opens up a double
attack on the night here so really not
much to do for doing here dingoes night
c4 attacks the rook ended the b61 twice
now and rugby 3 now goes after the b5
pawn and here Knight to d6 it goes after
the rook and the e4 pawn but look the a8
and now Geary also has some plans of
going R okay - Ruby - and then putting
some pressure on the White King directly
so rush of character son b6 and now
Knight to d7 attacking the bishop also
defending his c5 pawn we have Bishop to
c7 and now Bishop to b4 with chick
getting the bishop also into the action
King h1 and now III Gary creates his
second Passport
so Knight to c4 and now comes Luke to a
for forcing the knight to move with
Knight back to d6 and now rook to a2
with appliance of rugby - and then just
a well winning the game so tonight the
c4 ding prevents the roof from coming to
be too so now rook the c2 again pushing
the knight back and here the knight
cannot go back otherwise it's game over
so here at rook c1 and a Giri trades off
a pair of rooks captures captures and
rook captures on b5 now and now it's
giri who's up 2 points and those are two
passed pawns
we have Bishop to f4
Bishop to f4 by dink now putting
pressure on the e3 pawn but now e to
Gary just advances it and now G to a g4
making room on g2 for the king so you
don't run out of breeding squares
and here you could go for Bishop to f-22
threaten this but then Bishop F to
Bishop d2 kind of kind of guards it
so first Garrity decides to eliminate
the defender of the D 2 square and he
goes the Knights to be six I think not
interested in a trade he moves at night
to d2 and now rook tabi to just a very
strong square for the rook and rook to
e1 putting the rook in front of the
passed pawn but now Knight to d5 also
now just attacking the bishop if you
move it you're gonna lose the night here
so Bishop to h6
getting rid of both both threats but now
Knight to c3 you use this attack on the
undefended Bishop so you could switch or
Knight over to c3 the once again
defended the e to pawn so King g-tube I
think but now f5 we have Knight to c4
attacks the rook but rugby for attacks
tonight we have Knight to d6 and now
capture Sanji for recapture Sanji for
and now Bishop to e5 puts pressure on
the night but also on the G for pawn
here Bishop to d2 by thing not really
interested in moving tonight just
allowing rook captures and g4 check but
here it's pretty much the same deal so
here Gary just captured in these six
Bishop captures on c3 and now rook
captures and g4 with Czech king of three
and here giri played rook to h4 and it
was in this position that dink we were
and resigned the game and he fury
equalized the match and not only that he
got his first victory in the tournament
and it's not in any kind of a victory
some people were saying oh ding
blundered in Game three
no he didn't here in Game three now Gary
just completely outplayed thing and the
thing was nowhere near you know he was
really in this game at all it was all
Geary he out prepared him completely and
it was just a beautifully played game
you could never grab that d6 pawn and
Indian you just didn't know what was
happening so really really well stuff
and good Fergie to grab grab his first
win in the tournament so this is Game
three the matches now the match is not
tied we're going into Game four and if
that's also a type we're going into
Armageddon so that's the game
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Eric Pilkington Callahan cocaine
Robert Greaves Xavier Martin and and
Robson for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
video serum thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the Magnus Invitational
until it finishes
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day